c'est un moment de détresse et d'horreur
près de ses entrepôts de boudhha sous
cette couverture bariolés gagné par le
givre le corps de dmitri chaplin 20 ans
vient d'être retrouvé par ses proches
la dernière fois qu'il a été vu c'est
lorsque des soldats russes n'ont arrêté
assure ce membre de la famille ils ont
frappé ils ont emmené et personne ne
sait ce qui est arrivé après
ne la retrouve et qu'aujourd'hui il
avait disparu le 4 mars je crois
ucia comme dans plusieurs autres villes
autour de kiev récemment abandonné par
l'armée russe des dizaines de corps ont
été découverts ces derniers jours
certaines victimes mains liées derrière
le dos pourrait avoir été exécutés
moscou n'est toute responsabilité et
parle de mise en scène fomenté par les
autorités ukrainiennes
et few look qui polluent si vous
regardez attentivement ses ebooks ce
qu'il y à abuja les cadavres gisant dans
la rue une stricte il n'était pas là
avant que les troupes russes arrivent
ce pardon avant qu'elle parte
soudainement ils apparaissent dans la
rue
un discours us contredit par ces images
satellites diffusé hier par la société
américaine maksar cette photo a été
prise le 19 mars alors que la ville
était occupée par les troupes russes
déjà dans la rue la blonde ce cas on
distingue ces ombres qui pourraient être
des cadavres
c'est dans cette même rue que le 1er
avril ces images de corps gisant au sol
ont été filmée par un vidéaste amateur